this is the spiciest item to date for
Shake Shack
see those are the you know that's those
are the types that's what I need under
my hall of fame plaque you know like
those kinds of accolades
hey what's going on everybody from first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans coming at you
with a hot one special that has been
literally years in the making we're here
at Shake Shack's Innovation kitchen I'm
joined by Shake Shack's culinary
director Mark Rosati and we're here to
unveil the brand new limited edition hot
ones Shake Shack collab that's right a
spicy bacon burger a spicy bacon chicken
sandwich and spicy cheese fries that all
incorporate the Heat and flavor of hot
one sauces available exclusively right
now via the Shake Shack app and
available at Shake Shacks Nationwide
starting September 16th so to take
things back about four years ago you and
I met we talked about what was then
Shake Shack's first spicy chicken
sandwich can you talk me through how
four years later we've gotten to the
point we're combining hot ones heat and
putting it into the Shake Shack Universe
well that that was our hot chicken it
was like almost like we're dipping our
toes in the world of hot and spicy to
see like what people would dig it and I
got to try all your hot sauces recently
I'm like there's got to be a fun way our
worlds can come together so we found two
hot sauces that play really well
together and most importantly they play
really well with our Shack sauce here so
this being the Muse this is how this all
finally came together so is this like
Shack sauce the classic last dab forming
like Voltron yeah 100 we fell in love
with the classic the garlic the Fresno
in there works so well with all these
flavor profiles when the last dab comes
into play here that's when it gets
really crazy because we wanted to make
this hot we don't want to be like safe
with this here we wanted people to come
in and say okay Shake Shack and hot ones
what's this going to be like we want to
make sure this thing delivered all right
well it's enough Chit Chat Mark let's
make this step in here so let's first
add in here we have the classic just
gonna add that in scoop all this
goodness out
next we have the last dab here
if we add a lot of hot sauces and
they're all somewhat thin it's going to
make the sauce
yeah so the last dab we add a lot but it
also has great viscosity here comes the
honey to balance out all the picante
flavors and then the last thing we're
gonna do is a little bit of salt to kind
of bring it all together and balance out
some of that sweetness mix this together
wow there's a good amount of hot sauce
in here too because what's the
expectation here you want this to be hot
so we had to bring it beautiful
it's got a great great Aroma yeah
I'm getting hungry all this guy in here
so the sauce is kind of the thing that
ties everything together but we're here
to eat and we can't just snack on sauce
today no so Mark now let's start
stacking some sandwiches let's do it
[Music]
so what we're going to do here is we're
going to start off by putting our bun
down here we're gonna put the Patty on
there so this is our 100 all-natural
beef
what we're doing is we're putting
monterey jack on there I think when it
comes to like this hot sauce there's
something about the Monterey Jack that
pulls it all together better than like
an American or a cheddar would I have
some of that spicy Shack sauce we have
here put this right down it's a healthy
amount on it too because it's all about
this sauce here so we want to make sure
in every bite you get a good amount of
it full coverage yep
so now we're gonna put some bacon here
we've got some bacon I cooked off for me
like peppers and smoke have such a
Harmony together that this one demanded
something beautiful like this type of
bacon and that's it we're just going to
shut the bun there wow and there's a
deliciousness what a beaut where would
you put this on the heat scale one to
ten I would say it's a seven I would say
it's like it's in the medium category
but it's on the high side I'm going to
call it medium hot all right
[Music]
not just saying this
[Music]
the best spicy Burger I've ever had my
entire life whoa thank you thank you
what I love about this too is the last
dab is a little time delayed and the way
that it kind of builds with you so I
feel by the second bite it's like you're
ready to go it's like that creeper that
slowly gets there it gets there and then
that last fight oh my God all right well
let's move on to the next menu item
before I just eat this brush in one
second let's do it
[Music]
talk me through this sandwich so this
one here we tried a lot of different
things again like we want to try play
around because chicken is a different
animal now I mean the breading on there
it's highly aggressively seasoned and
the breast itself is slow cooked in
buttermilk so we tried a couple
different ways of building this here but
you know what adding pickles shredded
lettuce it wanted to be the same as the
burger so we're gonna let it do that if
that's what it wants here so what we
have is our chicken breast and we have
the jack cheese on there we're gonna put
some bacon on top of that too
[Music]
add some of this delicious hot one spicy
Shack sauce on here and that's it again
similar to the Burger but if it that's
what it wants to be why are we going to
fight against that we've got that
Harmony and the flavors how much hotter
is this sandwich than the hot chicken
that's eight years ago this is the
spiciest item to date for Shake Shack
see those are the you know that's those
are the types that's what I need under
my hall of fame plaque you know like
those kinds of accolades this is awesome
for us too I'm beaming right now I'm
beaming all right time to try the
sandwich
[Music]
oh so good and I think
for uh Hot Head
I think the sandwich might the chicken
sandwich might be a little bit hotter
than the burger the spice in the breader
itself that has aggressive seasoning so
I think it does push a little more I'm
just gonna work my way through this
sandwich
and we are gonna work our way to the
third and final menu item
these are the hot ones cheese fries
what's going on over here so this here
is a lepo pepper what we love about the
Aleppo pepper is while it's also
delicious it's got some spice to it so
we got our our Shack cheese sauce not
gonna be shy with it no there we go some
of the uh Aleppo pepper on top and again
I love the color of that because the
fries of the cheese sauce could be a
touch monotone so this gives it that pop
you're looking for and it brings in yet
a different Pepper and a different
flavor profile and the last thing you
have here is the hot ones spicy Shack
sauce to bring it all together so we
have our Shack sauce we have our cheese
we have our fries we have our Aleppo
seasoning how else can we step up these
fries bacon easy easy you can always add
bacon to it if you're that type of
person goes I want full in on this here
get the bacon add it to it and you can
take it to the next level if you want
and speaking of the people who want to
go full in yes is it true that there's a
secret handshake component to all of
this here it is we're actually going to
offer a packet of the last stab Apollo
if you want to take this to the next
level you want to do your own hot ones
challenge with your friends we're going
to have that which you can put on top of
it too and I mean how great are these so
if you know you know if you want to
Apollo this whole thing go ahead and
Apollo this whole thing just ask I love
these packets super cool so cool but I
also brought a bottle and the reason
that I brought a bottle of the last app
is because last time we grilled you we
put your feet to the fire with some
burning questions and I want to keep
that tradition going I got some more
questions for you but I think that it's
only right
that we just top off oh word our fries
with some last dab
to get this going
here we go
let's do it down it goes
um
such great flavor I know
but I can feel it building already and I
know that it doesn't stop it's clear
clearing out the sinuses all of a sudden
well now that I have you right where we
want you
what is oh
what is the biggest Innovation kitchen
fail like a menu item that you guys
tried out here
but thankfully never saw the light of
day there have been a couple there have
been a couple so I would say the one
that never saw the light of day that we
kind of had a little high hopes for is
we did this one it was a long time ago
it had jalapeno it had a raspberry in it
and the flavor works I can see it works
I don't know there's something about it
we never could tame the jalapeno it's
always a little too hot it was like a
little too mellow so that one just never
saw the light of day thank God
your favorite non-shake Shack Burger in
the United States right now oh there's
so so many I have to say right now
because I'm in New York City I have to
shout out Red Hook Tavern I think uh
Billy Journey the chef over there slam
dunk Burger it's simple American cheese
draped over a Patty slice of raw onion
on a delicious bun it's simple it's
perfect and if you haven't had it you
gotta go get it
ketchup on a burger the customer is
always right or please vacate the
premises please vacate the premises I
don't do I don't do ketchup on any Meats
I just not a fan I've always I've always
been to mustard because I think it
accentuates the beef don't even tell
like you're you're from Chicago
on a hot dog you know I would never if I
did I'd never say it publicly
I know I know how seriously people take
it Mark thank you so much and there you
have it it's the hot ones Shake Shack
collab menu and it is available now for
a limited time through the end of the
year make sure you tag us at hot ones
make sure you tag at Shake Shack show us
how you're handling the Heat
and the hot ones Shake Shack collab menu
it's here
get it while it's hot
because it is
[Music]